ce vendredi à gaza les mosquées sont
fermées au public une mesure inédite
dans ce territoire où les lieux de culte
sont ouverts même en temps de guerre
coronavirus oblige ce gazaouis doit se
résoudre à prier chez lui après avoir
fait le tour des mosquées c'est la
première fois en 30 ans que je trouve
toutes les mosquées de la bande de gaza
fermés surtout pour la prière du
vendredi
nous avons fait face à de nombreuses
guerres et les mosquées n'ont jamais
c'était fermé
je ne peux pas décrire ce que je ressens
je suis allé dans plusieurs mosquées
pour prier mais je les ai toutes trouvé
fermées dans le siècle
c'est très dur de constater que toutes
les maisons de dieu sont closes la bande
de gaza est en alerte même si pour
l'instant seuls quelques cas de kovy 19
ont été identifiés mais la crainte est
grande dans ce territoire surpeuplé sous
blocus israélien depuis 13 ans l'enclavé
pourrait être le théâtre d'un désastre
sanitaire si le coronavirus venait à se
propager largement les autorités
essaient malgré tout de rassurer en
annonçant la fermeture des points de
passage vers l'enclavé
le ministère de l'intérieur et de la
sécurité nationale a pris des mesures
plus strictes concernant les
marchandises entrant dans la bande de
gaza à travers des points de passage
commerciaux
d'autre part le ministère continue de
fermer les points de passage les
barrières et les peurs liées à la
circulation des personnes
le ministère de l'intérieur et de la
sécurité nationale continue également de
sécuriser tous les centres de
quarantaine dans tous les gouvernorats
de la bande de gaza face à une possible
catastrophe sanitaire l' oms a appelé la
communauté internationale à renforcer
son aide financière à la bande de gaza
de son côté l'onu a annoncé avoir
débloqué un million de dollars pour
soutenir l'anc là